- [Instructor] Caterina was testing
her null hypothesis is that the true
population mean of some
data set is equal to zero
versus her alternative hypothesis,
is that it's not equal to zero and then
she takes a sample of six observations
and then using that sample her
test statistic, I can never say that,
test statistic was T is equal to 2.75.
Assume that the conditions
for inference were met.
What is the approximate
P-value for Caterina's test?
Like always, pause this video and
see if you can figure it out.
I just always like to remind ourselves
what's going on here, so
there's some population here.
She has a null hypothesis that
the mean is equal to
zero, or the alternative
is that it's not equal to zero.
She wants to test her null hypothesis
so she takes a sample of size six.
From that, since the population parameter
we care about is a population mean,
she would calculate the sample mean
in order to estimate that and
the sample standard deviation.
From that, we can calculate this T value.
The T value is going to be equal to
the difference between her sample mean
and the assumed population mean
from the null hypothesis, that's what
this little sub zero means, it means
it's the assumed mean from the
null hypothesis, divided by our
estimate of the standard deviation
of the sampling and distribution.
I say estimate because unlike when
we were dealing with proportions,
with proportions we can actually
calculate the assumed, based on
the null hypothesis, sampling distribution
standard deviation, but
here we have to estimate it.
It's going to be our
sample standard deviation
divided by the square root of N.
In this example, they
calculated all of this for us.
They said hey, this is going to
be equal to 2.75 and so we can just
use that to figure out our P-value.
Let's just think about what
that is asking us to do.
The null hypothesis is
that the mean is zero.
The alternative is is that
it is not equal to zero.
This is a situation where, if we're
looking at the T
distribution right over here,
my quick drawing of a T distribution.
If this is the mean of our T distribution,
what we care about is things that are
at least 2.75 above the mean and at least
2.75 below the mean because we care
about things that are
different from the mean,
not just things that are greater than
the mean or less than the mean.
We would look at, we would say
what's the probability of getting
a T value that is 2.75
or more above the mean,
and similarly, what's the probability of
getting a T value that is
2.75 or more below the mean?
This is negative 2.75 right over there.
What we have here is a T table
and a T table is a little bit different
than a Z table because there's
several things going on.
First of all, you have
your degrees of freedom.
That's just going to be
your sample size minus one.
In this example, our sample size is six,
so six minus one is five, and so
we are going to be in
this row right over here.
Then what you want to do is,
you want to look up your T value.
This is T distribution critical values,
so we want to look up 2.75 on this row.
We see 2.75, it's a little bit less
than that but that's the closest value.
It's a good bit more than this
right over here, so it's a little bit
closer to this value than this value.
Our tail probability, and remember,
this is only giving us this probability
right over here, our tail probability
is going to be between 0.025 and 0.02
and it's going to be closer to this one.
It's gonna be approximately this.
It'll actually be a little bit greater
because we're gonna go a little bit
in that direction because
we are less than 2.757.
We can say this is approximately 0.02.
That's 0.02 approximately,
the T distribution
is symmetric, this is going
to be approximately 0.02.
Our P-value, which is going to be
the probability of getting a T value
that is at least 2.75 above the mean
or 2.75 below the mean, the P-value
is going to be approximately the sum
of these areas, which is 0.04.
Then of course, Caterina would want
to compare that to her significance level
that she set ahead of time, and if this
is lower than that, then she would
reject the null hypothesis and that
would suggest the alternative.
If this is not lower than her
significance level, well then she would
not be able to reject her null hypothesis.